comment ça va comment vous allez comment
ça roule aujourd'hui alors regardez on
va se parler aujourd'hui d'un sujet
intéressant c'est toute la notion de jeu
tient la caméra ne vous montre un peu
studio la notion de des plateformes de
youtube de tik tok de tous à comprendre
un peu le marketing d'influencé est ce
que c'est un truc qui va perdurer un peu
dans le temps c'est un peu l'idée alors
avant de parler de ça je voulais vous
montre un truc parce que je en train de
bosser ici je vous ai déjà peut montrer
mais il ya des gros changements à savoir
que la la voyez tout ça c'est mon bureau
où je me filme avec mes éclairage mon
bureau un peu classique mais quand j'ai
pris cet endroit et là je me suis dit je
trouve un peu plus modulaire donc je en
train de bosser dessus regardez je suis
en train d'installer mon petit coin
bureau au fond là bas et ce petit coin
bureau il va être trop cool parce qu'il
va me permettre de mettre des moniteurs
pouvoir travailler sur twitter enfin
lancé twitch je vais pouvoir un peu
avancé je vais pouvoir enfin rangé
menace qui est un peu sonné c'est un peu
le bordel donc faire un rack propre donc
tout ça ça va arriver ça arrivera très
bientôt je vais pouvoir enfin poser un
bout de déco ici au dessus de cette télé
parce que j'ai récupéré des trucs très
très cool de chez nano leaf ce sont les
line ce que vous voyez là juste à
l'envers bref tout cet espace là va
avancer et ça va être vraiment trop cool
voilà donc c'est une petite parenthèse
que je voulais faire avec vous et
maintenant je vais vous poser là dessus
regardez juste là un nouveau pied de
bonnes photos que j'ai acheté c'est pas
mal combattent sur une table et puis il
va garde pas une chose aussi au niveau
de la déco j'ai acheté plein dans pool
philip sion donc voilà il va se passer
des trucs
[Musique]
donc j'aime bien ce truc c'est un peu
différent un peu de traviole temps de
bouger page et c'est devant rim et la
tronche là vous m droit au web pop pop
up ah là là c'est à peu près droit ah
c'est pas mal j'ai bien skié ok alors
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de se parler de
marketing d'influencé alors pas pour
faire un truc de marketeux est passé des
heures à parler de marketing d'un
financement fait c'est un tout qui
fâchent mais vachement intéressant parce
que c'est mon job déjà moi de vous
parler directement ici sur youtube plus
haut sur différents réseaux est en fait
j'avais pas prévu de vous en parler je
n'ai pas réfléchi à ça et c'est
alexandre qui m'a contacté et qui m'a
dit tiens monsieur je connaissais pas
alexandre mais il m'a fait un mail et
m'a dit tiens écoute je suis en train de
préparer mon mémoire je travaille dans
une boîte et compagnie et dans le cadre
de mon mémoire je vais en tout sur le
marketing d'influencé j'aimerais bien
pouvoir en parler avec toi et est-ce que
tu accepterais de répondre à mes
questions pour m'aider dans mon mémoire
et moi je le dis donc on fait une petite
discussion ce matin et en fait en
discutant avec lui je me suis dit ça
serait cool de pouvoir vous en parler
pour parler un peu de marketing
d'influencé alors si vous ça vous
intéresse à tout le côté marketing
influence tout ce qui se passe dans mon
job est tout bon ok on y va on en parle
ensemble si ça vous intéresse pas en
reparlera tech probablement demain ou
après demain parce que j'ai tout court
vous montrer regardez j'ai reçu les
nouvelles wife erreur wayfarer de ray
ban ray-ban facebook donc ça on va en
parler dans quelques jours j'ai aussi
reçu le galaxy à 53 qui est là donc on
va sans parler et puis il ya plein de
trucs donc si l'idée de deux mondes
jeunes du marketing d' influence de la
vie des plateformes et de l'avenir de
l'influençant et le général c'est pas
votre domaine revenez demain sinon
pouvait rester jusqu'à la fin parce que
vous allez voir sujet super intéressant
le sujet de basses et de se dire ok
est-ce que l'influent telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
c'est un bulle spéculative est ce que ça
un truc un peu tendance trendy est-ce
que ça va durer ou pas et je pense qu'à
une vraie division là dedans alors c'est
un peu compliqué parce que je pense déjà
il faut aussi de redéfinir ce qu'est l'
influence et du coup le marketing
d'influents derrière en fait l'influencé
j'aime pas ce terme influence influence
influence et influenceurs je n'aime pas
trop mais j'ai pas de meilleurs termes
créateurs de contenu c'est un peu moins
un peu moins pompeux mais bon j'ai pas
vraiment le truc le truc parfait une
influence c'est quoi si vous voulez
avant qu'ils aient toutes ces plates
formes là qui existent pour pouvoir être
connue pour pouvoir parler de ce dont on
avait envie de pareil pour pouvoir
parler de sujets divers et variés ou un
humoriste se faire connaître ou à
quelqu'un qui était dans la tête qui
aimait à tech comme moi de pouvoir en
parler il fallait passer par des médias
ça pouvait de la presse écrite de la
radio pour être de la télé c'était super
compliqué de rentrer dans ce lia je
pense que s'il n'y avait pas eu des
plateformes comme youtube c'est
impossible pour moi donc en fait avec
l'émergence de ces plateformes s'est
passé un truc super intéressant ça a
permis à des gens qu'il y avait un
talent quel qu'il soit de pouvoir faire
entendre sa voix et ses plateformes
comme youtube comme facebook tik tok
instagram ou autres ont permis juste un
truc c'est de donner cet espace de
liberté aux personnes pour se faire
entendre et que des personnes en face
qui regardent puissent les découvrir
donc en fait c'est à dire de faire match
et une audience par rapport à ta lancée
l'idée ni plus ni moins sauf qu'avant il
n'y avait pas ces canaux pour le faire
donc pour se faire connaître il fallait
monter à la capitale et il fallait taper
aux portes des médias en espérant un
jour être prix d'or qui avait très peu
de places très peu d espace pour pouvoir
se faire connaître donc en fait c'est
comme ça que l'affluence est arrivé
c'est à dire on va se faire connaître on
a des supports et on peut le faire alors
il ya eu effectivement la notion de télé
réalité bien c'est un autre type
d'influencé c'est pas du tout on a là
qui a permis effectivement s'il ya des
gens d'avoir un peu d'un peu de filles
mais on celui d'arriver sur des réseaux
mais bon ça je sais pas mon truc du tout
donc on va pas en parler mais voyez est
typiquement pour moi dans la tête n'y
aurait pas youtube il n'y aurait pas
instagram n'aurait pas tik tok j aurais
pas youtube serait pas en train de vous
parler donc ces plateformes elle permet
de ça donc influencer ça c'est juste ça
c'est pas plus pas moins ça veut dire
que tant qu'il y aura des plateformes et
tant qu'il y aura des gens qui ont un
talent qui ont envie de communiquer que
ce soit un humoriste que ce soit comme
un mentaliste comme fabien olicard qui
peut être sur les réseaux et en plus de
ces spectacles qui va pouvoir tourner
bien pouvoir être là communiquer
directement avoir un peu de coulisses
vous voyez toutes ces choses là elles
soient importants grâce à ces
plateformes donc tant qu'il y aura des
plateformes il y aura forcément une
influence parce qu'on est des gens qui
ont des choses à dire peut-être que les
plateformes évolueront c'est une
évidence train pour mac n'est pas de
temps révolu si on regarde un peu
l'histoire des plateformes vous regardez
l'émergence
facebook est extrêmement fort et un
autre qui sont arrivés alors qu'on a
raté quelques-uns ils ont voulu rares
acheteurs qui n'ont pas réussi notamment
snapshot ça s'est pas fait mais voyez il
y à une évolution voit qu'à une
multiplication des plateformes donc
aujourd'hui youtube reste quand même
très fort au niveau de la vidéo est sur
le format londres dans un big thing tôt
qu'annoncé ya pas longtemps qu'on
pouvait avoir des contenus jusqu'à 10
minutes sur tip-top donkey maillard du
format long qui va se développer là
dessus aussi c'est juste une question de
forme a donc et d'algos après qui va
pousser certaines choses mais pour moi
le marketing d'influencé un truc qui va
continuer très clairement avec
différents profils je pense qu'il va y
avoir deux par la multiplication des
plateformes pas ce qu'il ya de plus en
plus peut-être des influenceurs qui vont
se spécialiser sur une plate forme et
pas sur une autre aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de vous parler comme je le fais là sur
youtube mais je me suis vidé sur du tip
top parce que je trouve ça marrant
s'informant un peu différent instagram
c'est aussi rigolo parce qu'elle est aux
affaires il ya la story et de
l'instantané alors on voit effectivement
que les plateformes elle essaye tout dès
qu'un truc qui marche de le même chez
elle il ya eu un snapshot instagram a
piqué les stores ils ont bissé facebook
et youtube essaye de le faire mais
j'suis pas sûr que ça marche trop bien
donc il essaie tous d'aller sur ce
domaine là donc il ya une multiplication
des plateformes et moi j'essaie d'être
un peu aussi sur différentes plateformes
pour pouvoir essayer différents types de
supports parce que ça me plaît bien je
trouve ça cool mais pour autant je pense
que la multiplication des plateformes ce
faisant et bien il y aura des
influenceurs qui sont très très forts
sur certaines plateformes et pas sur
l'autre c'est un peu le cas aujourd'hui
mais je pense que ça va être encore plus
le cas d'ici allez peut-être cinq dix
ans avec de plus en plus de plateformes
temps à vraiment le gros influenceurs là
et l'autre qui sera vraiment énorme la
même si aujourd'hui il a minima il ya
aussi un peu de ça donc en fait c'est ça
l'idée est inquiet de la plateforme tant
qu'il ya du divertissement tant qu'il ya
des choses à prendre en cas des choses à
montrer qu'il ya des gens qui ont un
talent de l'autre côté pour le faire ou
qui ont une expertise l'affluence ça
continuera donc ça c'est la base de
l'influencé cette rencontre besoin
divertissement plate forme avec des
talents ni plus ni moins et après le
marketing d'influencé quoi il ya des
marques qui sont dit ok bon on voit
qu'elle l'audience on voit qu'il ya des
gens est ce que nous on dirait pas
présenter des choses est ce qu'on dirait
pas tiens se dire ah bah tiens je vais
aller coucher
nouveau smartphone je vais les push et
des vêtements auprès d'audiences de ces
gens là ils comment est ce que je peux
me dire faire pour me faire connaître
donc les marketing d'influencé créé là
dessus parce que comme on le voit
effectivement ça c'est intéressant si
vous voulez parce que si vous regardez
la télé que vous écoutez la radio vous
regardez un magazine chez quelqu'un dise
mot des magazines mais bon vous avez des
contenus publicitaires qui est très
froid en fait c'est à dire que lorsque
vous regardez des spots télé vous avez
pendant cinq minutes la ribambelle ils
sont tous là et ils n'arrivent pas à
cibler autant on voit que google a
réussi vraiment un truc super fort c'est
à dire le ciblage publicitaire très
précis par rapport à vous parce qu'en
fait on partage tel monde date à dire
quand on va sur google c'est du contenu
gratuit donc lorsqu'on va consommer du
contenu gratuit on accepte le gratuit en
cédant un peu de data que vont venir
monétiser de l'autre côté sinon il faut
prendre que du payant et vous emmerder
pas leur aprilia les solutions ne va pas
on peut utiliser du tout enfin peu
importe qu'on s'en fout c'est pas le
sujet donc c'est plus par dans les idées
à force de là dedans donc l'idée en fait
pour les marques c'est de se dire ok
vous regardez sur un je vous dis ça à la
télé les pubs c'est du contenu hyper
froid donc qu'est-ce qui se passe les
marques se sont dit on va aller
contacter une personne dans l'affluence
quelles qu'elles soient et quel que soit
le profil et on va lui dire maintien ça
serait cool que tu puisse parler de
notre truc temps l'audience elle
correspond à nous c'est l'idée parce que
si vous avez un taux qui correspond pas
ça marchera part d'audience correspond à
nous on a envie de montrer les choses et
on pense que les gens ça va vraiment les
intéressés donc là vous avez un truc qui
est un peu vertueux qui est intéressant
est ce intéressant pour les marques
pourquoi parce que quand on suit
quelqu'un sur les réseaux et qu'on vient
régulièrement la voir c'est quand le
général son expertise nous plaît son
talent nous plaît et surtout on finit
par s'attacher un peu aux personnes donc
il ya un truc est très forte pour les
marques là tu sur le marketing
d'affluence en disant il ya un
engagement qui est énorme en fait et
c'est un contenu qui beaucoup plus chaud
que de faire du mass médias en balançant
des pubs à tour de bras bien évidemment
si vous prenez une pub juste avant le jt
vous avez touché tout le monde la
ménagère et vous allez faire du volume
de dingue mais si vous voulez venir
toucher une cible en particulier vous
trouvez le bon profil et c'est ça qui
est le marketing d'influencé en fait et
c'est intéressant quand c'est bien fait
quand ces vertueux c'est à dire j'ai le
bon produit qui va correspondre à la
bonne personne qui va intéresser la
bonne audience avec le bon discours il
faut que la personne derrière le talent
qui présente ça le fasse de façon
déontologique pas si c'est le terrain
parce qu'on n'est pas dans un domaine
médical mais qu'il le fasse avec
beaucoup de sincérité et une vraie envie
faut que le produit marché qui est
vraiment envie de le présenter à son
audience donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant aussi avec l'e marketing
d'influencé mal à battre est en fait moi
quand je fais par exemple ce genre de
choses où ça décolle avec des matchs ont
fait quelques unes mais la plupart des
choses comme je vous présente la loyer
avec le galaxy à 53 on n'est pas du tout
dans l'idée du marketing d'influencé
même si la marque elle est contente que
je le prenne et que j'en parle mais
c'est plus un côté média journalistique
si je suis pas journée c'est pas de
carte de presse mais c'est cette idée là
en fait c'est moi mon point de vue et
même lorsque je vais faire des
partenariats avec des marques payante si
je veux déjà dit dans une autre vidéo
l'idée c'est pas d'être en hausse en
août se travestir l'idée c'est d'être
honnête je parle d'un produit parce que
j'y crois parce que je trouve
intéressante quoi qu'il se passe même si
ce produit intéressant qui a des défauts
je vais vous le dire parce que c'est
important donc bon c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui donc en fait le marketing
d'influencé saint lô pour moi c'est un
truc qui va perdurer dans le temps il va
y avoir une multiplication des
plateformes il va y avoir probablement
une spécialisation par plate forme ça va
continuer tous ceux ou celles qui n'y
crois pas je pense que si parce qu'il ya
de toute façon toujours eu cette notion
si vous voulez un peu d' influence que
ce soient des acteurs qui est bien été
forcément influents dans leur domaine où
elle est donné des envies de certaines
choses parce qu'on les voyait avec
certaines freins dont les voiliers avec
un produit bref donc cette notion l'inde
a toujours existé maintenant il faut
être très clair et revenir à la bad en
fait le truc de l' influence c'est juste
cette rencontre entre une audience et
une personne grâce à une plate forme
alors que ça n'existait pas avant donc
c'est ça donc le temps que y aura des
plateformes ça continuerait alors après
on peut se poser la question de plate
forme parce que les plateformes c'est
quoi on va regarder à les placer mais
plus connu you tube tik tok installera
pour apprendre que ces plateformes mac
est ce qu'elles veulent c'est faisable
en fait ce qu'elles veulent c'est que
les gens restent chez elles et que les
gens soient contents et qui partent pas
donc dès lors que vous proposer un
contenu que le contenu se regarde sur la
plate forme et que vous restiez sur la
plate forme et ça permet à la plateforme
de vivre en plaçant ses pubs c'est
gagnant gagnant pour tout le monde et
c'est ça qu'elle veut l'on a vues sur
youtube arrivé un peu de vod on peut
venir payer pour avoir un film mais
j'imagine pas youtube de venir en aide
flix demain voyez avec un abonnement
alors il ya du premium mais c'est juste
pour éviter les pubs j'imagine pas
youtube vous dire ben nous on va créer
nos propres contenus tous ces gens qui
ont des talents qui viennent poster
leurs contenus directement ça ne paraît
compliqué aujourd'hui leur fermer la
porte donc effectivement et on voit en
plus si vous regardez les plateformes
comme netflix
on a au csa vous connaissez amazon prime
disney + et compagnie et il y en a
énormément qui vont arriver encore aller
paramount et compagnie dont il y en a
énormément fait d'avoir plus en plus cet
espace là il n'est pas fait pour à mon
avis des plateformes comme youtube qui
elles vont vraiment rester dans la
création de contenu talent pur qu'ils
vont accompagner pour leur permettre de
vivre et toucher leurs pubs et de faire
évoluer les plates-formes et de faire
évoluer les supports je pense que de
toute façon fait pas semblé route
continue à exister comme ça dès lors
qu'elle d'audience et dès lors que les
gens ont envie de découvrir des talents
ont vite découvrir du contenu on vit de
sa forme et ont envie de se divertir ça
va continuer et ça ne changera pas parce
que les gens ont envie de se divertir
ont envie de se faire plaisir ont envie
d'apprendre au travers de plateformes
avec du contenu gratuit donc il est
évident qu'un youtube qu'un tic toc ou
qu'une plateforme qui émergera demain
qui râlent et remplacé qui sera la
nouvelle plateforme trendy du moment va
continuer à exister l'audience a
toujours là et toujours captif pour
découvrir de nouvelles choses qui vont
les intéressés et il ya toujours des
gens qui ont plein de talent et qui ont
envie de les montrer qu'ils ont envie de
les mettre en valeur de toutes façons
l'affluence ça va continuer le marketing
d'influencé va continuer il est évident
qu'on ne maîtrise pas les plateformes
boyer typiquement moi c'est un peu mon
truc donc dans mon job c'est un peu le
problème c'est à dire que moi je
maîtrise par youtube même si aujourd'hui
on est quoi on est ça s'en va mieux je
suis super content vous avez si nombreux
sur youtube c'est dingue mais l'évidence
même c'est que en fait c'est de mon
point de vue très abstrait parce que je
sais qu'il ya cinq cent vingt mille
personnes ont cliqué sur le bouton je
m'abonne et qui du coup sont là ils
suivent mais pour autant demain je suis
plus sur la plateforme où la plateforme
va changer le ciel devient un peu moins
trendy et que moi je dois aller ailleurs
il est évident qu'en fait il n'y a rien
fait je veux dire j'ai pas à 520000
email pas vous contacter vous écrire des
matches je suis là je les rejoins donc
on est dépendant des plateformes ont
c'est tout le problème de mon job à moi
c'est de se dire ok comment est-ce qu'on
peut réussir à exister sur ces
plateformes comment est-ce qu'on peut
réussir à anticiper l'avenir de ces
plateformes et comment est-ce qu'on peut
préparer l'avenir pour continuer à vivre
sur ses plates formes pour pouvoir
continuer à partager sa passion et
pouvoir les yeux dans les yeux vous
regardez vos dires m j'ai trouvé un truc
marrant je vous en parlais en fait
travailler je suis chez moi en fait je
suis en train de vous dire regardez chez
moi et je vous montre mon truc je vous
montre là ce que je suis en train
d'installer mon bureau et je partage mes
découvertes je partage ma passion donc
c'est tout le problème de mon job c'est
de se dire comment je peux faire ça et
comment ça marche alors il faut
comprendre comment marche des
plateformes et il faut comprendre où est
ce qu'elles vont qu'est ce qu'elles
veulent et jusqu'où on peut aller ça
c'est un peu le nerf de la guerre quoi
voyez c'est se projeter dans l'avenir
c'est extrêmement passionnant donc il ya
plein de plateformes il ya plein de
façons différentes de partager cette
passion et j'en fais du jeu sans trop
cool c'est un peu flippant parce qu'on
maîtrise pas l'avenir mais d'un autre
côté je vais vous dire quel est le job
aujourd'hui dans lequel on maîtrise
réellement l'avenir qui n'a pas des
masses mais voilà moi j'ai la chance de
faire un métier qui me plaît énormément
que j'aurais jamais pensé pouvoir un
jour possible parce que quand j'étais
plus jeune je puisse me pratique depuis
je suis gamin quoi j'aurais adoré
pouvoir parler des coûts parler d'autres
trucs mais il fallait déjà se dire ok
alors comment est ce que je peux faire
forer dans des médias faut taper à la
porte de télé est à moi j'étais petit je
regardais la télé en famille tf1 m6 et
tout est grossier qui existe encore
aujourd'hui mais tu te disais je fais
quoi je suis provincial ce que moi je
suis clermont ferrand j'suis provincial
qui monte à paris je vais aller voir
bonjour ben voilà j'aime la tête je me
rends parler chez vous jamais jamais
donc ça c'est génial que cette
plateforme puisse exister qui me
permettent de faire ça et de vous parler
en direct comme ça sans filtre sans
intermédiaire est juste la plateforme
donc c'est génial voilà je m'éclate et
je voulais en parler vous parce que je
trouve aussi un sujet qui est super
intéressante pouvoir se comprendre en
fait comment ça marche de parle un peu
plus de mon job de ce qu'est l'
influence qu on appelle l influence
alors c'est un peu la croisée des
chemins parce qu'en fait il ya tellement
de types de personnes et puis la notion
de moins influent sera vachement
galvaudé et c'est un espèce de gros sacs
fourre tout dans lequel on met tout le
monde c'est à dire que détecté sur une
plate forme actuelle influenceurs mais
j'ai l'impression que des fois avec
d'autres personnes qui sont sur la même
plate forme off et des métiers qui sont
tellement différents ils ont une
approche qui est tellement différentes
que j'aime ce qu'on fait pas le même job
moi j'essaye vraiment d'avoir une
approche journalistique dans mon taf
journaliste j'ai pas de carte de presse
de toute façon je suis mon propre média
et qu'il ya des partenariats avec des
marques c'est moi qui dis avec les
marques donc l'option de journalistique
ça n'existe pas et ça n'existera pas
donc voila mais c'est avec la façon de
bosser que ça doit être le but
ajouteront les galaxies à 53 5 g et que
je vais aller dans la rue le tester que
je vais vous donner mon retour est
parfaite je suis plutôt l'idée de votre
pote qui vous du maintien obtiendra j'ai
découvert un nouveau produit regarde ce
qu'on peut faire c'est ça c'est un peu
moyen donc ça n'a pas forcément fait
pour vous pour vous pour toi mais ce
truc là c'est bien c'est intéressant at
elle pris donc voilà c'est ça l'idée en
fait et c'est ce que permettent de faire
c'est la tente donc voilà donc c'est
cool je ne vous le racontez ce pas que
ça vous aura intéressé tandis que le
mans en commentaire et puis si vous avez
des questions sur cette notion d'
influence de marketing de comprendre
comment ça marche et si vous voulez
qu'on en reparle et si vous avez un
sujet que vous voulez qu'on regarde et
qu'on approche ensemble vous me le
parquet renvoie aux commentaires et puis
on craindre à sa vaste une vidéo un peu
différente je sais mais voilà il faut
faire des choses différentes parce que
sinon sinon c'est pas rigolo j'espère
que ça vous aura intéressé vous embrasse
pour le soin de brouiller très vite
[Musique]
et